[Music]
thank you
[Music]
happy December 1st to everybody and
welcome back to the data science hangout
hope you all had a great week last week
we were offer for Thanksgiving
and so if you're joining us for the
first time today this is an open space
for the whole data science Community to
connect and chat about data Science
Leadership questions you're facing and
getting to learn about what's going on
in the world of data science across
different Industries
we share the recordings each week to our
our posit YouTube so you can always go
back and reward re-watch or find helpful
resources
we are putting them up to our new posit
data science hangout site just is taking
a little bit longer but they will be
there
together at the hangout we're all
dedicated to creating a welcoming
environment for everybody here so we
love when you all can participate and we
can hear from everyone no matter your
level of experience or area of work
and I had a dream last night that I
forgot to say this part next and that
nobody was talking and I don't know why
I had this this dream but there's always
three ways to ask questions and also
provide your perspective
um so it doesn't just have to be a
question if you have something you want
to weigh in on or a certain topic
but one you can jump in by raising your
hand on Zoom
two you can put questions into the zoom
chat and feel free to put a little star
next to it if you want me to read it out
instead if it's in the zoom chat
and then third we have a slider link
where you can ask questions anonymously
um one more thing we also have a slide
uh sorry a LinkedIn group for the
hangout too so if this also helps you
connect with each other we'll share that
in the chat in a second here
we've learned that you do have to
manually turn on the notifications for
the group using the little bell at the
top if you wanted to do that
but with all of that thank you so much
for joining us here happy to be joined
by my co-host for today Christina
Fillmore data science leader at GSK
and Christina thanks for joining us here
I'd love to have you maybe start by
introducing yourself and sharing a
little bit about your role
maybe something you like to do outside
of work too
um okay so hi everyone my name is
Christina
um despite my American accent I do live
in the UK I'm not sure if you can see it
is dark outside
um so um I thought that's my fun fact
um I work at GSK and I work within the
biostatistics space and one of the main
roles right now um that you kind of see
across a lot of Pharma are kind of
moving Pharma moving into the r space
and starting to use r as a primary tool
in order to report clinical trials so
one of my main jobs today is
um actually just like writing a lot of
our packages for our specific beads
Pharma does a lot of things that are
like very Pharma
um that are just like if it whether it
comes from doing things like the way we
format tables and create tables Pharma
does stuff that most com like most of
the times you don't do things like just
in the world of tables because that's my
most recent package so I can talk all
about tables and table design as
interesting and exciting as that is to
anybody
um is things like we tend to make mock
tables like we make a fake version of
the table we want before we have any
data
um and then we like use that fake
version to make the date make the table
we want much later down the line but
oftentimes the fake version of the table
happens six months to a year or even
more depending on how long your study is
to like making that table so doing
things that make it so that it's easier
to kind of work through the Pharma
Pipeline and allow for automation while
making our packages is basically my job
um which is really long-winded way to
say I make our packages
um but that is that is what I do uh and
I think that was all your question my
last question was uh what is a hobby I
have outside of work and I would say
knitting I knit this jumper I like
knitting
that's awesome
cool they I was debating if I'm going to
walk into one of these little pods down
the hall because all of a sudden the sun
is coming in here in this room like
crazy but but I will wait a second thank
you so much Christina
um I was curious just to start off a
question about like getting to make
packages and having that be a big part
of of your role sounds awesome and I was
just curious to learn a little bit more
about the team that you're on
yeah so I'm in a pretty small team
um there are four of us on my team and
we do the like
kind of majority issue of the package
building here at GSK at least for our
internal use and to some external ones
um there are other people in our
community who help with other projects
like the Admiral project their p and
Admiral package there are people in our
department who do that but I am not one
of those people I do kind of other
pharmac things I currently hold
like within the Pharma verse I'm the
person who writes packages to deal with
metadata I don't know how this has
become my life like it was an accident
um it wasn't like I love metadata but so
I have three primary packages that I
maintain within the farmerverse uh
metacore which does deals with metadata
around data sets
um
meta tools which uses that that metadata
to do fun automation stuff and t format
which deals with metadata around
formatting tables so that's like all of
the metadata I hold in my like World of
pharma-based metadata
um but that is so that's that's kind of
like me and then yeah my team is really
they're it's primarily me and like Becca
Krauss who's on who does safety Graphics
um and Alice Hughes whose um news does
Bell tools so there's kind of like all
of us have our own packages as well um
but those those are the ones that we
kind of maintain right now
cool sorry that was a very indirect
answer Rachel it's the end of it no my
excuse
that was helpful and thank you I made my
journey down the hall into this new room
where the sun wasn't uh in five days
there
um thank you so much Christina and and I
was I was just also wondering listening
to share about the different packages
how does the team decide what to work on
or prioritizing which one at the moment
the priority has really been developing
a pipeline for us that's usable
um the kind of that talk for us the kind
of the clock is ticking for how long
we're going to keep using SAS or I mean
well that's not true we might always use
that but like we want to fully developed
pipeline for our
um and so really like how I started and
how it's kind of gone from this point is
looking at this Pipeline and saying what
do we need in order to have the things
that we need if we have all of these
things we can report a study
um and so really that was the where the
target is for us
um and specifically for like me and kind
of my team identify it's we try to
identify where there's not already a lot
of people doing the same thing
um there's kind of a influx of people
into like
Pharma building our packages right now
um and like there's a lot of people
doing things that do like kind of
calculations for instance
um
and
we're not necessarily ex like I came to
this role this came into this world by
being a clinical statistician I used to
be the person who's like designed sample
sized
studies
um and then I like needed some things
and I was like I'm gonna build a shiny
app to do some sample size things for me
and like over time I became the shiny
person who then kind of built some
packages and like I then I more like
fell into this role then was like I am
today going to be a data scientist it
was really based on my own needs and the
needs of people around me
so like that's how I fell in here and so
because I'm not a clinical programmer I
really do my best to not take over some
like within the Pharma space some of the
reporting and stuff we do I guess this
is a very sorry I'm very Pharma
jargoning right now basically within
when you're reporting a clinical trial
there's two people who do like the
database the data set things
in terms of like job career people is
like
clinical clinical programmers and
statisticians like clinical statistics
the statisticians tend to maybe run the
final analysis the main big one that
tells you whether the study works but
there's a whole bunch of things that you
need to do like
get the number of people in the study
check that like look at all the safety
Adverse Events and calculate the number
of Adverse Events there are
um which are not really doing like
you know traditional statistics they're
more like means standard deviations like
all of the data sets cleaning up all of
that sort of stuff and that's
traditionally been done by someone
called a clinical programmer
um and so I have never been one of those
people um and so I always say I just
play one on TV but I tried to leave the
and and my group isn't full of people
who were that role so I try to leave the
stuff where it's like you need really
in-depth knowledge to understand like
how particular things are calculated in
data sets like the people who work
clinical programmers are really good at
that because they can bring that
knowledge to the table because I can't
that's my attempt to avoid doing those
things
um and to try to focus more on things
where I can add value
um that way so
thank you and I see there's a lot of
people who have joined us since I first
said this in the beginning so I just
want to remind everybody I see a lot of
questions starting to come in now but if
you just join welcome thanks for joining
us you can ask questions using a slido
link if you want to ask anything
anonymously and we'll share that again
in the chat in a second but feel free to
just raise your hand to jump in as well
I see um Alan you just recently put a
question to the chat do you want to jump
in
yeah that was good coffee timing there
um I so Christina I think I was typing
this at the same time you were starting
to describe those other folks who were
kind of Downstream of the work you're
doing and I was just interested in like
what that collaboration is is like are
they if you think about like your most
direct customers are they those clinical
programmers and others who are on the
like the study specific teams or do you
have a different like what's the motive
of interaction there and how do you
figure out
um sort of who kind of who to be
responsive to and when as as studies
come along as study milestones are hit
and things like that like is that stuff
you're engaged in or are you a little
bit removed from the you know like study
conduct itself
I would say yes to everything
um so on one level I'm a little bit
engaged uh removed from it in that I
anything that I'm actively building
hopefully isn't also being used in a
trial like we try our best not to like
be trying to fly a machine while
building it that seems not ideal so we
don't tend to do that
um but at the same time those clinical
programmers are oftentimes the people
who I work that I work with them a lot
and they are major customers for me
because if I write functions that they
don't understand how they're going to
work together and fit and they don't
make sense to them and don't solve
problems that they're having they are
useless I I might as well have drawn
like a picture for myself maybe it was
probably would have been easier
um but they're also not my only
customers because depending on what I'm
doing so like
for my
data set metadata packages they actually
basically are my only customers but for
the like table formatting one
there are other people who are even
further down the line than for instance
a clinical programmer because the
clinical programmer makes all these
tables to hand over to somebody else
called a medical writer who then like
writes the clinical study report that
goes to the FDA
and so like
those people become are also like my
customers because they have needs like
we need to ensure that the like typeface
meets the FDA requirements because it
turns out the FDA only accepts like five
different fonts and that the like
margins have to be very particular and
there's like all sorts of rules that
they know and I do not
um and so like they are my customers
from that like and are the things that
I'm making still do they still like meet
those needs
got it cool thank you yeah of course hey
Marlene I I see you have your hand
raised too do you want to jump in
heck yeah I do good morning everyone or
I don't know what part of the world
you're in it may not be morning but it's
morning where I'm at Christina thanks
for joining us and co-hosting with
Rachel
um
I'm super thrilled for you because I
feel like you're in a place that I kind
of want to be at so I'm having a little
bit of Envy here
um but my question stems from kind of
like a twofold I'm trying to figure out
structurally where you sit in your
organization so are you under I.T
informatics are you somewhere else
um also how what was the road like to
get to that position and to have a
pipeline set up because I'm the only our
user in my company and right now I'm in
I'm scrambling to build kind of a
Sandbox playground VM place to start up
some of the this work and then to start
to have to be the Pied Piper for other
um analysts and scientists in the
company to kind of start to play with
Aaron and and find a safe space to kind
of work and and then eventually maybe be
in that position where I write packages
like you do yeah yeah so my history like
so I sit within what's a department
called biostatistics so in these like
massive Pharma companies you usually
have a department full of statisticians
and clinical programmers who do the
reporting out of the study and the
designing of the study so that's the
department that we sit in and we grew
out of a need to support that department
um building out things like we actually
started with really supporting the
statisticians primarily and doing and
building tools for them to help design
trials like that's that was like kind of
the need that I had as when I was a
statistician and so like that ended up
being the tool that I built
um with others not just me like we have
some really brilliant statisticians here
who know math more than I do
um and they're very good at the math but
maybe they don't know how to be how
always to come like we are a big
department
um just guys like a big company that I
don't even know how many statisticians
there are but many
um like probably at least two to three
hundred or something like this the like
statistician who knows how to do a
particular analysis type or like for
trial design can't sit with all 200
people when they need help so we started
building out some shiny apps to help
them like to help people design that so
that is how we started we being my
entire department like um because I kind
of have our Department's not very old
it's been around
God but like I thought four or five four
years five years so we're like a fairly
new Department Within
our sub Department with my larger
biostatistics Department
and I've kind of been around since the
beginning so that's how we how our
department largely started and then
as we started building those sorts of
tools
some of the there's a request to hey we
want to move to trying R for clinical
study reporting and so as we started to
move to that that's how we started
building packages for that need and it
was really
that was that's more or less how it
happened
um for both me personally and me as a we
as a whole sub-department
thank you thank you yeah
I want to make sure to get to some of
the anonymous questions over on slido
too so I'm going to go jump back and
forth but I see one over there was years
ago GSK had a very specific extensive
SAS macro system it said it even had a
name which I now forget is the Corp now
doing this with r
um
I so I don't know what the Grand Vision
is I I am not puppet master
um but I would say we are really trying
to focus as much as possible as doing
stuff in the open source um so I think a
lot of the extensive macro system that
we currently have today which
um I don't know if I'm allowed to say
the name of I don't know what the rules
are I'm not going to say the name of
because you didn't so
just keep it that way um
it's a little like the one that shall
not be named
um
that macro system like a lot of what it
does are things that like you know
Admiral and other firmiverse packages
are kind of taking into place and doing
and are really our goal as like
the larger firm Rivers is to do our best
not just at GSK but like other Pharma
companies to as much as we can kind of
Open Source all of these kind of complex
macro systems into things that everybody
can use it makes it easier for everyone
and like when we're hiring people for
instance we can hire someone and then be
like yes I have used all of these Pharma
specific R packages because I come from
Pharma and we don't have to spend
six months or whatever training them for
our complex macro system instead it's
more like
here are some of our prophecies but you
should feel comfortable with most of
these things because you've probably
been somewhat exposed to them so that's
like one of the reasons that GSK is like
looking at Farm reverse and helping in
farmers and involved in that way because
of those sorts of spaces
thank you and just for clarification
because I think this was one another
earlier question was what what actually
is the Pharma verse I'm so sorry I'm no
no worries this is when you go when you
spend too much time in Pharma we all
have so much jargon and we say it to
each other so much that we forget what
jargon even is
um I think we all do that
um so yes the Pharma first is a group of
packages that is all open source thank
you Eric
um you just put there's a website just
for it um but basically it's a series of
packages that really look on building a
kind of Pharma end-to-end because the
Pharma workflow is somewhat standardized
I mean the FDA and the EMA have
requirements they're like you need to
have a data set and it's called an atom
data set and it looks exactly like this
and you're like okay great and so
there's not like everyone does their own
thing and gets to be creative about how
that data set works if you do that the
FDA will be like no thank you go away
make the thing I've told you to make so
because there's like
there and with standardization can come
Automation and you know like overall
improvements
um
so that means that like we're really in
the Pharma verse is trying to like get
some of that Automation and that time
saving and stuff like that
possible because you
um
because because of that so that is what
the pharmacist
we're going to make through like five
questions Rachel and I'm so sorry no
this is this is great and uh I love
seeing everybody helping out in the chat
too and sharing links as well thanks
Eric I see Eric you had a question
earlier too do you want to jump in
be glad to uh great to hear from you
again Christina
um I'm curious back to your discussion
about obviously open source work
um how does your team kind of prioritize
that type of work versus your more
quote-unquote day-to-day
responsibilities at GSK and what is
leadership buy-in been like to give your
team support to work on state department
or Survivor
um sets that are happening in the
industry because I think it's an
exciting Trend but admittedly I do see
some pockets of Industry slow on the
uptake on this being a really core
importance here just curious your
thoughts on that yeah so um thankfully I
work under Andy Nichols who I don't know
both people probably won't know that
name but yeah Eric knows the name which
is important some someone does he helps
the like there's the thing called the r
validation Hub he like very much loves
our and the open source
um and so we had to do a lot of kind of
groundwork laying but now most of my
time is actually spent on dealing stuff
dealing with stuff in the open source I
would say
80 of my time is doing stuff like that
and building packages for the open
source and then sometimes building
internal like compendium packages to
make those open source packages work for
us internally but like I would say it's
largely open source work is what I do
um so and but that's not necessarily how
it started out but I think having
leadership like a having Andy do all of
the talking to be like open source is
important has been great
um so have have yourself in Andy is my
top recommendation
um outside of having yourself and Andy
uh I think
for us I mean the farmer versus been
really great because it has been a
collaboration where other Pharma
companies have also said it's important
um and so you're able to like no one
wants to be the only one out there
putting open source stuff out like
that's the [ __ ] that feels very
uncomfortable when you're like standing
alone in the wilderness and you're like
I am alone but as everyone started to
put stuff together now we can really
talk to our leadership like it's
important to do open source because if
we don't do it and if our voice doesn't
get heard here sometimes it means that
the way we want things to be done might
not be done that way because somebody
else built it and now that's really
popular and that other person built it a
while ago and everyone uses that and
it's going to be hard to like change
course changes change the ship that's
already I don't know some ship analogy
um about moving ships and so
that is why like I think that's
generally the argument that we use when
talking about the open source
um and also
you'll hear something oh I can't
remember the exact phrase but like
Pharma my
General
career path
like we're not an I.T company the day
GSK becomes an I.T companies the day I'm
like please and it's like this is bad
um so we don't want to be an I.T company
we want to deliver people like make
drugs and help people live better lives
like that's our goal as a Pharma company
not have become an I.T company so us
developing software that helps everyone
like deliver on the thing that we're all
supposed to be doing
it it's easier to argue that that's not
intellectual property for us because our
intellectual property tends to be things
like molecules uh and like that that's
like that's a thing that we make and
that's what we we do we don't we're not
an I.T company
um and so that's that's the other thing
to like
just where we are in the the world of
stuff
I see a lot of excitement around the
farm averse and in the chat right now
Libby and John talking about other
Industries have something similar John
do you want to jump in
totally thank you um so Christina um
Libby and I and a lot of other people
have been talking about trying to to do
something that's inspired by um the
farmer verse um but more for human
resources um and trying to sort of pull
together people in different companies
to sort of build packages together
um we have far less standardization and
honestly HR analytics is pretty poor um
so anything they consider help raise the
bar would be really good at 95 of the
places they're probably 99
um so any suggestions on like how to
kick start um a movement of getting
people together
um or any Lessons Learned um from the
former verse that's what we sort of do
or avoid
um I don't personally believe you need
to have a Big Splash in order to start I
think if you wait for a like a big
beautiful website and everything to be
working before you try and get into
anything you're gonna just like be
waiting is a circle
um so I firmly believe finding some
friends and start developing packages
with them is like a great choice and it
doesn't have to be a huge number I mean
it honestly like I wasn't necessarily
Run for the whole origin story of the
Pharma verse but like part of it grew
out of something like Michael rimler and
Michael and Mike Stackhouse two people
who are not here and probably you don't
know but basically like they were like
we should build some packages together
and I was like okay and they were like
Christina come help and I was like okay
and I built a package for them uh with a
tourist so a different company that um
is not even a big farm it's a Sierra
like we and a cro like built a package
or two together and then like the the
mics were having more conversations with
other people and all of them there was a
beautiful website and I was like Wow
everything's coming together
um and so like
to some extent it's just like talking to
people and then starting to build stuff
eventually you'll have enough stuff that
you will have your own verse
um but I highly recommend starting and
in terms of the like things aren't
standard what do you do and how do you
start sometimes a nice starting place is
a package that helps standardize stuff
metadata is not really in a standard
format in Pharma everyone has their own
like way of holding this metadata it
kind of gets standardized to a thing
called a Define XML but that's only like
right at the end of the day typically
that Define XML comes together
as you're like sending the thing to the
FDA it's not like that's it's it's not
ready at the beginning
and so one of the first packages that I
built as part of the Pharma verse was
this package called metacore
um as I said I'm like I hold many
metadata things don't know why but part
of the reason was we wanted to build
automation off this metadata but
everyone held it in a different Excel
format typically or like it was in a
database but like it was their own way
they they designed it their way it's
different for everybody so we needed to
have a thing that we could all look at
and be like this is the thing and we all
use this thing and this is how it works
so like what metacore came for us it's
just like an R6 object
um it's just an object like it's the
most boring package in the whole wide
world it it does almost new things it
sits there and you can poke at it but
like that's it but that enabled
additional automation to be runoff so
then like we have a different package
called meta tools that does a lot of
this automation
but the first step was getting that
thing we could all agree on was like the
thing we were using and it doesn't have
to be perfect
it's a great Point thank you Christina
so we have a ton of questions here on
slido as well that I see coming through
it so one Anonymous one was
um the learning curve is steep from cozy
SAS programming to from averse or red
open source any suggestions for newbies
transitioning from SAS to R and python
um my first suggestion is like
try doing a thing that you kind of
generally know how to do that thing in
fast like if you don't run AIML models
in SAS don't be like I'm Gonna Learn R
and start with AIML models because
that's a thing I've always wanted I know
it's a thing you like even if you want
to get there eventually it can be
helpful to start in a place where like I
know what this data set should kind of
look like at the end so I'm going to do
something similar
um so that's like my my first general
recommendation but I would also say it
like
I really like the r for data science
book I think that that one's really good
um we are trying to we being the farmer
the people of the farm rivers are trying
to pull out some some sample uh like
sample code used to build like a
standard ADSL
um you're saying you're coming from
staff so I'm going to use farmer words
at you um so like a standard data set um
so you can start doing things that you
kind of are familiar with
um but but those are my general
suggestions
um at some point you just kind of gotta
do it and that will make it will get
easier with time because it's December
1st I'll also recommend like Advent of
code it's a thing I like to do I mean
the questions get really hard towards
the end and so if you don't can't do
them in art don't worry I can't do the
minimum either
um but like just practicing problems
I think going from SAS can be hard
because it's not an object-oriented
language
um sorry if you can see my cat behind me
so I'm sorry if you can hear him he's
decided now and we love having perhaps
join the Hangouts too see if they want
to jump up yeah he's calling for his
people
um anyway
um but but yeah SAS is not object
oriented and I think getting over that
first hurdle of like
having an object-oriented like which is
the hardest but then it it does get um
easier after that
and I see lots of people posting links
look at other people's links they seem
great
I I really like that don't start with AI
ml models there too is
just reminding me Travis of your
LinkedIn post yesterday about like
Spotify rap is like the most popular
like data science right now just
counting how many times you listen to
something
um Travis I I see you asked a question a
bit earlier do you want to jump in
sure hey Christina
um I have a question about how you
access data so kind of like one of these
boring admin questions but knowing how a
lot of so for those not in Pharma
they're kind of some software Giants in
the space that provide solutions to make
electronic case report forms possible so
at the clinic or wherever your clinical
trial is being facilitated people have
to enter into an interface like this
patient had this disorder and this event
happened on this day so there's
companies that called things like
metadata and Viva and inform and the way
they deliver out data is typically not
by way of giving you access to an API or
keys to a database rather they have
modules that kind of do nefarious things
like email data to you
um have you all and
um in encountered a better way of making
this happen because that's that's one
part of the the data stack and Pharma
that feels woefully behind the times are
you all hitting like a research data
warehouse or something more fancy than
just like you know the nastiness of
unsecured data transfer so uh short
answer uh no long answer GSK has a
lovely Department called data management
that manages that data and hands it to
us in biostatistics as sdtm data so
because we get sctm data like and that's
how our departments worked and my job I
mean back to Priority how does the
priorities of what packages get made for
us today largely is set on what my
department needs my department doesn't
have to worry about yucky data formats
to sctm or trying to get those sorts of
things from an ecrf into an sttm
um which that so that is why I don't do
do that and that's why I we've not
looked at it yet that's not a no ever
it's just a
thankfully it's not been my problem but
I sympathize
yeah fair enough
yeah I I'm just you know because like a
lot of these data managers are now being
rebranded as clinical data scientists I
think is the new phrase that's it's
going around yeah so is that is
happening at gsk2 like because I have to
do more of these sort of
semi-complicated data engineering things
yeah I've heard the name bandied around
I don't know if it's like a g going to
be a GSK thing or not oh where has been
a GSK thing I honestly so many people
are changing their name titles to data
scientists now I don't always keep it
straight
um
right it's a great Club everyone can be
in the club I'm not gatekeeping the club
I just don't remember who has joined the
club this week uh so
foreign
I don't have more of a better answer
no that's fine thank you
Billy I see you put a few questions into
the chat as well do you want to jump in
next
oh bill says no I think one of the
questions was
um
Christina if this is happening across
GSK globally or if it's like your team
is also us-based or UK based
oh yeah uh so as I said maybe in like
earlier when very few people were on uh
despite my very American accent I live
in the UK it's dark outside it's the end
of my day so I'm blaming everything on
the fact that it's almost it's 5 30. I'm
checked out
um so
um yes no we are we're doing this
globally
um GSK is like one global company so we
as the biostatistics department for all
of GSK support all of GSK um my
department is quite spread out despite
being not very many people like my
little group so my little group is um
really like four people
um and we are spread from London to
Seattle
um and so we we cover cover a lot of
time zones for that and yeah we we work
for all of my or like all of my
Assistance Department in GSK but also I
mean other departments with ndsk as well
but yeah
cool thank you
going back to some of the slido
questions
um when you were talking about tables in
the beginning someone asked could you
explain how tables and R specifically
relate to the work being done by GSK
um maybe a few examples or real use
cases
yeah so um tables when I talk about Tay
when I was talking about tables then
sorry my cat is now trying to climb out
the window that is closed it's very
strange
um he doesn't normally do that uh anyway
desperate times I guess
um
so when I talk about tables I talk up I
mean like
demographics table as in the number of
people who are like goes like male
female it goes you know here's the age
cut down like mean age max age Min age
what and like by treatment so it is like
the standard like a standard it's
different for every company
um but it is a table that we give out
for
every study that has ever run at GSK I
mean there or you can have specifics for
like this the table that is for your
particular stats analysis for your
particular study but when I talk about
tables I mean like that sort of table
um and that table we at the like can
create an r or cannot create an R it
doesn't really matter
um and then like needs to get formatted
in a very specific way
um to meet those kind of medical writing
requirements I was talking about before
where they're like it needs to have
these particular margins this particular
font
um this is how we want it to look to fit
with our standards
um and so that is
that's kind of like the tables we tend I
tend to talk about
um and this year with my team
um we developed a package that takes
something called an analysis results
data um which is a long skinny data
standard that kind of C disk is
currently pilot like piloting
um but basically the idea is rather than
having everybody because what happens
for the most part today
um I won't say through all of Pharma but
through most of Pharma is that
a clinical programmer
maybe like maybe their job today is to
make a demographics table for their
study so they're going to make this
demographic State well they're gonna you
know do all the calculations that they
need in order to get the like ends that
the number of people who are um
like over 65 and the number of people
who are under 65 and all sorts of things
the average weight the percentage of
people who are over 65 Whatever by
treatment
they'll make that table but then
somebody else comes in and Q sees that
table but like when they're cue seeing
that table they might be like oh all the
numbers look good but the spaces are off
now I'm going to spend two hours arguing
with spaces yay and everyone has a bad
time so we don't want that that seems
bad so the analysis results metadata
idea is that rather than having to QC a
formatted thing you can QC the analysis
results metadata data which is long and
skinny and the point is it's much easier
to QC you can just put all your ends and
rows and presents in rows and you know
make it tidy data everything is good for
everybody but then at the end of the day
the medical writers still do want a
thing that looks like a table that's
easy to read or the clinician who's you
know trying to understand we've run this
study the stats say this thing but like
they need clinicians look at things and
like to understand what happened in the
study so
we need to make it so
easy for them so one of the things that
we did is create this package that
extracts some of that formatting into
metadata so that the clinical programmer
can just create a long and skinny data
set call their job done and dusted and
the metadata sits elsewhere the metadata
can be created when you create these
mock tables which is
so sorry for anyone who's not in foreign
but like basically before you start the
study you like draw out a picture and
you're like I want to take demographic
table that looks like this picture and
then so then the clinical programmer has
to do a thing that looks like that
picture but it our idea is rather than
have it as a picture have it as metadata
and then the clinical programmer just
makes something long and skinny and then
because you wrote the metadata to draw
your picture it will like make your
picture and you will be happy because it
will be exactly what you said
um and so that's how how it works
um
if that makes any sense trying to
explain code in abstract is hard but so
that's our tabling package it really is
more tabling formatting and yeah when we
talk about tables it's just like the
demographics table that the clinician
will look at or the program a medical
writer
thank you and don't worry about the
Pharma specific stuff I see John thank
you it says knowing nothing about the
industry it's still very interesting I'm
glad
I see a few other anonymous questions
over on slido and one was I'm assuming
you look for Open Source Talent when
hiring has this profile changed over the
years
uh
our Department's not that old so
um yes and but the years that we've been
looking are are slim
um so it's it's more that like our
Department's like five five-ish years
old the people we have hired in have
mostly been like people who had other
open source packages particularly in the
Pharma space
um because they were like you you
clearly do this thing seems great
um and and they were they've been great
um and I've loved to work with them so
uh I I would say
yes has a chance I can't I can't I
there's not been enough years to say
it's changed
thank you
um I see so many helpful links and
comments shared in the chat too so I
just wanted to remember to say this um
because sometimes people ask you can
save the chats if you want if you use
like the three dots on the right hand
side you can save the chat there too
just wanted to let everyone know when I
see all those links I try to to collect
them all and share them but if you need
them right away if they're there
um
another anonymous question was is any
collaboration with the FDA or other
agencies being done to adopt more are
based workflows
so
yes
um there are a variety of working groups
I am not personally on any of them where
the FDA also sits on the working group
um for instance and like other
collaborations have happened for
instance there was an R submission
um that they submitted a pilot study
into the FDA and but it was like a pilot
study it wasn't real and anything it
wasn't real data I mean it was in the
right format but it's thank you Eric and
um
the
those sorts of working groups are and
how it's being done and like the pilot
study the FDA was like happy to review
it they like spent their time doing
things like
they would have reviewed a real study
which um we definitely couldn't have
done without them being totally willing
to do that
um but yeah
um
that like I I I'm not on so yes but also
they're not like
Eric you can correct me if I'm wrong I'm
now pulling you into this as they don't
tend to like be on a huge number of
working groups and they don't I've not
seen them release any like our packages
where they're like this is what we're
doing to like actively help they they
want to help us as in like the larger
Pharma Community but they're also not
like building a lot of stuff I don't
know Eric that might be wrong you're not
yeah yeah most of that is definitely
correct although we are making sure that
the code or products were developing are
in the open so that other farmers can
use those the way they see fit and where
we're where we're at currently is in
Pilot too with so many a shiny app in
the fda's submission portal and that
will be obviously all the code that
we're doing is open source right now
I'll put a link to that and GitHub as
soon as I stop chatting here but in
terms of like people want to get
involved with that effort
um the best place to go would probably
be our GitHub repos and bio and issue
and say you'd like to be a part of it
and we'll make sure our leads for the
working group can get you involved in
but it's an exciting time right now and
it does move kind of slow sometimes but
we made a lot of progress in the last
couple years compared to where we were
before so it's pretty exciting
awesome bill I see your hands raised you
want to jump in yeah first um am I am I
on yes you are yep I don't get this
stuff anyway
um uh first uh uh Christina thank you
very much for your work over the RN
Pharma conference it was it was really
great so I appreciate that and I think
Eric too I don't I don't know the other
guys but um I have this this question
that I've posted many times so Pharma
sorry to non-farma people they're like
Lemmings even more than anything else if
one person does something then they will
follow so the key event the key over the
cliff event is the exception the
acceptance of a submission
by the FDA from some therapeutic area is
so I I like to think that that might be
oncology
who's in the lead here that you can see
or is or is there any lead anywhere
uh because there's a lot of resistance
internally
um by by many clinical data data
management biostats uh things that's my
question
I would say it's hard to say
um I don't I don't have a real clear
like this is definitely going to happen
like this way I also think
it's a
yes the answer is I don't know
um I don't know who's winning but
I I
think it might I mean things like the
Admiral packages where there's Admiral
specific to a particular like thing
um there's like an admiral Uncle there's
an admiral role about virology like yeah
other there's a couple of Admiral
specific ones that I think
um
those are a great start
um I feel like uh it I don't know
exactly where the change will be
um I think it's going to be more slowly
over time than like one particular
section switching everybody over I think
at least how the GSK approach is
um
with like choosing SAS versus R when
you're trying to to do something is
largely whatever the like programmers
feel comfortable with our goal part of
our goal of moving to R is getting to
like
making it so that people I mean there
are a lot of new grads and things who
are coming up who like only learn are in
grad school and so
like we want people to use what they're
comfortable with
um and so to some extent
that's that's like one of the many
reasons we use R we like R for a large
variety of foods but also it's kind of
what people know so I feel like at least
from what I think I see in our
department it's going to be like these
this you know
clinical study like clinical this
programmer who's running this study for
a submission feels really comfortable in
R like they've done a lot of our stuff
they love R so they're gonna like push
their team to all use R and then like
those are kind of the submissions that
like we've started to prepare
a submission
um in our where like the the production
is R the qc's and SAS
um to the FDA and like but that was
largely spearheaded by people who
um felt comfortable doing things in our
yes and I saw you laughing when I said
the QC is done in SAS because we are
Pharma and still risk-averse so don't
you worry we're not we're not there yet
thank you Christina I I see Daniel you
also had a question in the chat do you
want to jump in sure yeah hey it's great
to hear all this this great stuff I I do
not work in Pharma I work in
transportation a lot of this is very new
to me and um some of the strategies that
you mentioned are new to me as well and
it might be a naive question but I'm
interested to hear a little bit more
about the interaction between the
metadata tables that you're responsible
for and the downstream uh kind of work
that involves those so just thinking
about like the critical tables with
content from the studies you know the
users or you know the the participants
and all the other information
um and how that relates to the metadata
and like what that actually looks like
for the downstream analysts like how do
they put the two together like what do
you pass to them that kind of thing
so um this is like one of our newer
our packages
um so it is something that like I
maintain my team helped me build like I
couldn't have built it without Ellison
Becca so
um just to give everyone credit as the
lead thing but also part of what we
built is based off of very Pharma
specific workflow so just like I'm gonna
put it out there and in Pharma we do a
thing where you like make a table that
is full of nothing but X's
where you're like this should be
treatment this should be Placebo this is
the label and then there's like I want
this to go to like x x dot X because I
wanted to go to one I want it rounded
you know only once or like so you do
this whole thing you draw out oftentimes
sometimes in Excel sometimes in word
like the thing you want it to look like
and that's what's called your mock
um so what we've done is we've basically
made it so that this t format package is
a package where you can put this
metadata in to say like I want things
that are labeled
and for instance to be rounded to
nothing you just want like no decimal
places but I want things that are
labeled as mean that are part of I don't
know the group age to be rounded like
this and you put it all in
that then
um so that's just an R script where you
like can put all this metadata in
um our Grand Vision although we're not
there yet because
time and The Limited number of people
and resources is to have that right out
to a Json file it kind of looks like a
Json now we just pretend in our heart it
is when in reality it's just an R object
um and that that our object is then
um what's used whenever you have the
data so the data has to get into this
semi-standard format called an analysis
results data which is just tidy data
honestly
um you could use any tidy data data set
as long as it's like long and skinny
like that
um and so
the plan would be that the clinical
programmer just makes that that data set
and and then they can
we can store the media which is in our
pretend Json but is now just an R object
um and you can just like it's basically
kind of plug and play so you can put if
you have a really standard table for
instance you can use the same metadata
over and over and over again and just
swap out the data sets you can go as
many times as you like and we'll make at
the moment it goes out to GT um we'll
probably keep that forever because PT is
great like Rich has done a really good
job
um it makes all the things that we want
it to look like for the most part
um and we've had to work with Rich a
little bit in order to get things
there's some additional things that
we've needed
um and like Ellis worked with Rich in
order to get it to write out to word for
instance which was important for us and
he he did that and that was amazing and
so like it's we've we work with like
people like you uh Rich to like
our goal as a like GSK Department
largely is to not build and maintain
everything but to work with great tools
that already exist so yeah that was so
that's how we would see it work is that
once you have this Gat object it can go
to all of the things you want like it
can go to your PowerPoint or can you go
to PDF that can go to word it can go to
RTF
um HTML whatever and from our
perspective we can hold the formatting
metadata in
a pretend to Json and then just apply it
to as many data sets as you want it to
be applied to
that's really fascinating we'll put put
in the chat the the thing actually I can
I can do that I don't have the message
off the top of my head right this second
Eric you've been really good can you
pull up the t format website do you know
where do you have it I'm just asking you
because you might no that's teeth get it
shortly it's on the way
yeah so T player does something similar
except for it does the analysis as well
um and our goal is to not do is to
separate out the analysis and the
formatting because oftentimes you want
to change your mind on formatting there
are times that you like especially in
Pharma there are times where you're like
presenting some slides to someone or
something and so you don't need it
rounded out to the the like exact right
decimal or because you're just trying to
tell a story or you're for instance once
you finish the clinical study report
send it to the FDA and all the things
you do need to like publish it we also
we publish these papers and so sometimes
journals are like we have p-value rules
and your p-value needs to be rounded
differently and then once you if you say
if you only save the rounded p-value
it's then like can't round or rounded
value right so um you might have to
rerun the analysis which is bad we don't
want to do that um because you have to
read QC everything so like our goal goal
is to separate out the analysis and the
formatting and so that's what kind of t
format does did
thank you Eric you're the best
thank you I know we have a few minutes
here so I want to check to make sure I
haven't missed anybody's questions
um whether on slido or in the zoom chat
so feel free to just raise your hand to
or unmute and jump in if there are some
burning questions you want to make sure
are answered
but I I will ask you while we're waiting
to see who maybe raises their hand or
what I miss what is something that
you're most excited about thinking out
to maybe the year ahead
in the Pharma space or in open source in
general
I think in the year ahead the thing that
I'm starting to see the most is like I
really am starting to see this like
complete end-to-end solution like we're
almost there
um
excluding Travis's problems with things
that before they go into sdtm but that's
not my world so in my head it's complete
even though it's not complete for
everyone but I I get to care about
myself here so it's fine
um so like it's depending on where you
start end to end
um and that I like
I love to see that um and so
um I think that really will
to some extent
that will also start making it easier
for people to do that transition I think
one of the things that has been a
barrier up till today is that without
every single building block in place in
terms of like we need an R equivalent
for everything it can kind of be hard to
move into that to be like okay we can
now we agree and we're willing to like
take the leap and try r on a study
um and it might sometimes it's like for
stuff you know you won't even need for
that particular study or that particular
moment but just to being able to say to
your leadership don't worry that thing
exists if we need it which I don't think
we will but we might uh can be like
helpful in terms of like getting
leadership by
e thank you Christina and when I just
asked if there are any other questions I
see one Anonymous one that came in and
it was if not wrong during R and Pharma
someone mentioned that Roche and someone
told me I've been pronouncing rosh wrong
so maybe correct me is transitioning to
our entirely in 2023 is GSK or anyone in
the industry on the same path
we are currently on the path of Choose
Your Own Adventure
um like as I said to let people do what
they want and what works for them
um and so that that is the GSK party
line and that is what I know
um so
yeah I I don't know of anyone who's
doing that quite that extreme level I
mean Rush has been to some extent more
they've they've had a lot some of these
two balls longer um they're starting to
open source more and more of their stuff
but like they've had our tables for a
really long time which has been open
source for a while um but they they
that's what they use and build and great
um and so yeah I'm not surprised that
they're a little further ahead than
everybody else
um in this space
so
one last question I'd love to ask you is
I see a lot of your involvement in R and
Pharma and conferences and workshops
that you've LED if there are people
listening in who want to get more
involved in the Pharma Community what do
you think is the best way to get started
the best way to get started is a
um as kind of you have to choose what's
right for you I would say um to Eric's
point if there's a working group that
you are really that you love like make
an issue and they probably need your
help
um if there's a package that you love
and want to be involved in
um ask the package maintainer this
includes me
um I am the soil maintainer on uh a lot
of my packages and sometimes I have
other help for my from my group but
sometimes I'm the only one who does the
thing so if you are like I have looked
at your packages and I also love
metadata with a deep and burning passion
or you don't but you have some like want
to help I would love that so
um because I have one person and so yeah
I would say contact people for the most
part in the r Pharma space people are so
open to help and very receptive
um so I I've yet to go go up to someone
and been like I have a pull request for
you and then be like no you don't uh
yeah most people are like thank you
that's amazing so I would say generally
it's really an Arms Wide Open sort of
community
it's amazing thank you so much Christina
and if people do want to get in touch
with you is it through GitHub that you
prefer is LinkedIn better GitHub is
great LinkedIn is good I like it's kind
of um another option is I am on the like
there's a farm of our slack so you can
go on the farm reverse flag I'm uh
available there as well so I would say
whatever works best if you send me a
message on GitHub that's probably like
you probably need to put an issue on one
of my actual packages to for me to see
it but um uh you can also yeah link
LinkedIn or Slack are probably the
easiest ways to get a hold of me unless
you have an issue on one of my packages
or wants to be involved in a very
specific one I don't know which case an
issue will be great
perfect I just put your LinkedIn into
the chat as well thank you so much
Christina for for joining us today and
and sharing your experience
yes thank you for having me and uh thank
you Eric for for being being my buddy
and doing links for me that was very
helpful yes thank you thank you for all
the the great questions and resources
shared in the chat too have a great rest
of the day everybody